let's talk about the hair have you
always had amazing hair
i i was born with it did you see that
you saw that we saw that but
what's the what's what's the secret
what's your what's your tip
um once again the book covers that
there's a there's a number of uh
certain concoctions uh i make my own
hair gel
one of the recipes i use are eggs
uh bourbon half a bottle uh
beer preferably shaffer four cans
maple syrup rotten apples coconut milk
paint thinner shoe polish
20 billion cubes 20 cubes of water
cat urine yeah wet newspaper and cream
of broccoli soup okay
you mix that you mix that up you make a
thick paste okay
uh-huh you put it in the oven yeah 350
for
three days yeah and uh
and then apply liberally yeah i'm
telling you really get it in you'll get
this stuff you've got to be a great
adult thank you yeah i've got quite a
you know have you ever been in prison
no i i have not i've not been in prison
they would eat you up oh yeah
i'll know next time you go to prison
i'll go with you
if you're about to commit a crime let me
know let you know i'll be an accomplice
and i'm like i'm with him
okay yeah terrible idea um you have tips
for what kind of uh
breath turns a woman on yes um i've
found over the years that
there's no there's no finer and more
powerful aphrodisiac
on a woman than your hot breath and uh
have a number once again a number of
different recipes
different types of breath one is called
the executive
and
i don't know why that's funny no and
basically
all you need to do is eat sardines and
smoke an old cigar
okay okay and then you breathe that onto
a woman read that on the woman and it
just says i'm here
and you are in for a heck of a night
okay
it's like a beautiful soft summer breeze
wafting over a garbage dump
sure i'm not i don't know i'm not going
to go in waves sardines
hits them the olfactory senses and then
the cigar just
oh god it says in the book that you
slept with bruce lee
i did i slept i did i do you slept with
bruce lee
i did and it wasn't a homosexual thing
it was just
it was a very it was the height of being
manly okay how was it i had nothing
against
homosexuals but it was just two men and
uh
it was it was fast and furious much much
the way he
he uh he fights there's like two
wolverines going at it in a burlap sack
and i don't know what hit me uh and at
the end of the night we just bowed and
said konichiwa
i'm actually proud of him very proud of
it